[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم يشهد مخيم بلاطه في الضفه
الغربيه هدوءا مشوبا بالحذر بعد اشتباكات
بين مسلحين في المخيم الواقع في مدينه
نابلس ووحدات من الامن الفلسطيني اقتحمته
فجر السبت لاعتقال من تصفهم بالمطلوبين
للعداله وقد انسحبت قوات الامن في نهايه
المطاف من الازقه والحارات التي انتشرت
فيها وعادت الى مقارها نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين ما هي الاسباب الحقيقيه للاشتباكات
بين اجهزه الامن والمسلحين في
بلاطه وما تداعياتها المحتمله على المشهد
الفلسطيني سياسيا
وامنيا
اشتباكات فلسطينيه فلسطينيه في بلاطه هذه
المره بين مسلحين ووحدات من اجهزه الامن
اقتحمت المخيم الواقع في نابلس بالضفه
الغربيه بدعوى البحث عن مطلوبين للعداله
ومع ان هذه الاشتباكات لم تسفر عن خسائر
بشريه وانتهت بانسحاب رجال الامن الى
مواقعهم فانها بعثت مع ذلك برساله مقلقه
للغايه عن الوضع الحالي للساحه السياسيه
والامنيه الفلسطينيه
تقرير زياد
بركات ليسوا جنودا اسرائيليين بل
فلسطينيون لا يتجولون في مخيم بلاطه في
مدينه نابلس بل ينفذون عمليه امنيه لقد
اقتحموا المخيم فجرا لاعتقال من تقول
السلطه الفلسطينيه انهم مطلوبون واذ فعلوا
وجدوا انفسهم يشتبكون بالرصاص الحي مع
المستهدفين وذاك غدا مسلكا ت كرر اكثر من
مره في مخيمات جنين ورام الله ونابلس تحت
العناوين نفسها ماذا يحدث في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هذه المشاهد توضح صوره يجتهد
بعض الفلسطينيين لانكار فقبل اسابيع قليله
فقط اشتبك مئات من رجال الامن الفلسطيني
مع المتظاهرين وفضوا بالقوه القاهره مسيره
في نابلس خرجت احتجاجا على ما قيل ساعتها
انه قتل تحت التعذيب تعرض له احد شبان
المدينه اعتقل الشاب بتهمه التورط في
اغتيال ضابطي امن ولم يخرج الا جثه هامده
عليها كما قال ذووه اثار تعذيب تكرر الامر
لاحقا وتمسكت السلطه الفلسطينيه بروايتها
فهي تلاحق مجرمين ولصوص وقتلا وتسعى
لانهاء ظاهره السلاح غير الشرعي والتغول
على القانون يحدث هذا بينما يقول معارض
السلطه وبعضهم من داخل حركه فتح نفسها ان
الامر يتجاوز ما هو وجنائي الى ما هو
سياسي فثم تصفيه حسابات تتوحش بين محمود
عباس ومحمد دحلان تجري قبيل انعقاد
المؤتمر العام لحركه فتح ويقول هؤلاء ان
بعض المظاهرات خرجت احتجاجا على قرارات
لعباس فصل بموجبها وجمد واقصى عددا من
كوادر الحركه لانهم مقربون من دحلان في
المقابل تعرض وفقا لهؤلاء عدد من قاده فتح
المقربين من عباس من بينهم عضو في اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
لمحاولات اعتداء بعضها يرقى لمحاوله
اغتيال ووفقا للبعض فان ثمه مخاوف تتزايد
من انتقال الصراع بين عباس ودحلان الى
الشارع وتحديدا الى المخيمات ما يعني حربا
داميه بين من يفترض ان يكونوا رفاق السلاح
الواحد وما حدث في مخيمات الامعري وبلاطه
وجنين على وصف هؤلاء لم يعد حوادث منفصله
بل ان تراكمها يؤشر الى احتمالات ب حرب قد
تكون مفتوحه ومتدرج الى حين انعقاد مؤتمر
فتح
العام اما لماذا يحدث هذا فيعيده البعض
الى ما يسمونه مسعى اطراف عربيه لاستباق
اليوم التالي لما بعد عباس دفع تلك
الاطراف حسب هذه القراءه بدحلان الى
الواجهه وطلبت من عباس التصالح معه
والسماح بعودته الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وهو ما اعتبره عباس تدخلا في الشؤون
الفلسطينيه وبالتوازي بدا حمله يصفها
البعض بالتطهير للقضاء على انصار دحلان في
الحركه بعض المستهدفين وفقا لمنتقدي ما
يفعله عباس يتمتع بشعبيه داخل المخيمات ما
يجعل من خطوات عباس الاستباقيه معركه
صائبه ربما لكن مع العدو الخطا على
الاغلب نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من
نابلس خليل عساف منسق لجنه الحريات العامه
وعضو قياده تجمع الشخصيات المستقله في
الضفه الغربيه من رام الله احمد غنيم
القيادي في حركه التحرير الوطني الفلسطيني
فتح ومن غزه الدكتور سفيان ابو زايده
القيادي في حركه فتح نبدا بخليل عساف في
نابلس ما الذي اوصل الامور هناك الى هذا
الحد مساء الخير لك ولجميع الاخوه
المشاهدين تحيه الى كل ابناء شعبنا تحيه
الى الاخوه الاعزاء الضيوف يعني الجميع
يعلم ما هي الحاله الفلسطينيه التي تمر
بها الارض المحتله هذه الايام هناك حاله
من البطاله هناك حاله من الضغط الهائل على
كل ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني قياده وفصائل
وشعب وان اقصد هنا اكثر ما اقصده هو حاله
البطاله والفقر والافكار التي يتعرض لها
الشباب والعائلات حاله الضغط الكبير التي
يتعرض لها كل مواطن فلسطيني حاله التثبيت
للاحتلال وال استجلاب لقطعان المستوطنين
ليس بالعشرات وانما بالمئات والالاف هناك
حالات المصادره الكبيره التي هي يعني ايضا
بالاف الدونمات لم نعد نتعود يعني منذ
سنتين كنا نتعود على مصادره 10 او 20 او
30 دونم الان شيء طبيعي ان نسمع شهريا
هناك مصادره
23 و1000 دونهم وبالتالي هناك حاله غضب
هائل داخل الشارع الفلسطيني احد الاسباب
الاخرى هي حاله الانقسام التي يعني اصبح
كل ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني تهين بها
وبالتالي نحن اصبحنا
امام حاله معقده حاله يعني تركيبه معقده
داخل الارض المحتله واقصد بالضفه الغربيه
وقطاع غزه اتكلم هنا عن الضفه الغربيه اي
حاله الانقسام انا اعزي كل ما يحدث من
اسباب سيئه الى حاله الانقسام لانه لا
يوجد هناك مراقبه لا يوجد هناك متابعه لا
يوجد هناك محاسبه لكل الاخطاء التي تح حدث
على ارض الواقع وبالتالي انا اقول على
جميع الفصائل على جميع قاده الفصائل على
جميع النخب السياسيه واخص بالذكر الاخوه
حركه فتح التي مصر على القول دائما بانها
العمود الفقري لكل الثوره الفلسطينيه اذا
كانت هذه المنظمه واذا كان هذا التنظيم
بخير انا اقول بان كل الشعب الفلسطيني
سيكون بخير اذا انت انت تشير
الى عفوا انت تشير الى ما سميته حاله حاله
بعد اذنك يعني انت تشير الا ما سميته حاله
معقده في الساحه الفلسطينيه ولكن الموضوع
ايضا يقدم بطريقه اخرى وهنا اسال السيد
احمد غنيم ايه القصه طرحت رسميا على انهم
جماعه من المطلوبين للعداله
وجرى جرت ملاحقتهم في المخيم هل فعلا
القضيه بهذا الشكل الجنائي كما تروى
رسميا يعني انا لست بصوره ال موقف لدى
الاجهزه الامنيه على اي خلفيه دخلوا الى
المخيم هذا السؤال كان يجب ان يستضاف به
الناطق باسم الاجهزه الامنيه ولكني اعتقد
ان ما يحدث في بعض المخيمات الفلسطينيه
ليس بمعزل عن المشهد السياسي العام نحن في
حاله انغلاق سياسي كبير وفي ازمات كبيره
المخيمات هي المخزون المستمر والدائم
للثوره الفلسطينيه واي احداث فيها يجب ان
تعالج بحكمه وبحكمه عاليه وانا ضد ما يعني
ما يحاول البعض ان يوحيه بان هناك حول حرب
مفتوحه او كما ورد بالتقرير
الفلسطينيين لن يكونوا جزءا من المشه
تقرير التقرير اشار التقرير اشار الى
مخاوف التقرير اشار الى مخاوف في هذا
الاتجاه وليس الى حاله راهنه
الان اخي محمد انا لن ادخل في جدل في هذا
في هذا الموضوع انا اعتقد ان ما يحدث في
بعض المخيمات
الفلسطينيه هو جزء من المشهد العام ولا
يجوز تضخيمه لدرجه ان نقول ان هناك في حرب
مفتوحه او في تهديد في حرب مفتوحه هناك
الكثير من العقلاء في حركه فتح وا اعتقد
بانه سيتم معالجه هذا الملف الحساس والمهم
بطريقه عقلانيه وبحكمه عاليه وتضبط هذه ال
الامور فيما يتعلق بالحالات لماذا وكيف
هذا السؤال يجب ان يعني يسال للعناوين
اصحاب القرار في هذا الموضوع نحن مسؤولين
في قياده حركه فتح وكاع وكوادر في حركه
فتح عن المساهمه في بشكل كبير في النقاش
الداخلي في داخل حركه فتح للخروج من من
هذه من هذه الازمه ال البنيويه والتي تكاد
تصل الى ازمه وجود في داخل حركه فتح الى
بر الامان من خلال المؤتمر القادم المؤتمر
السابع المن يعقده في نهايه الشهر القادم
نعم الكلمات المتردده المتردده لحد الان
احتقان انغلاق حاله معقده ق ازمه وجود كل
هذه المفردات سيد سفيان ابو زايده هل هل
تجعل مما جرى اكبر من مجرد حادثه وانما هي
تعبيره عن شيء
ما ربما اعقد مما يبدو على
السطح
يعني هي هي كذلك يا عزيزي هي الامور اكثر
تعقيدا مما
يتحدث عنه الاخ العزيز احمد غنيم واكثر
تعقيدا مما حاول ال الاخ خليل يعني ب
بادبه تقديم هذه الصوره اي الوضع يا
عزيزي ان الصوره التي تنقل ان الاف الجنود
الفلسطينيين من قوات الامن الفلسطينيه من
لحم ودم وربما منهم من ايه ايه يعيشون في
هذا المخيم وعائلات في هذا المخيم يقتحمون
مخيم بلاطه وقبلها كان الامعري و قبلها
كانت هناك مشاكل في قلنديا الصوره بان
المخيم
هو عامل
اي يسيء او يضر او يشكل خطر على الامن
الفلسطيني وعلى المشروع الوطن الفلسطيني
هذه الصوره يا عزيزي غير مقبوله يجب ان
اذكر المشاهد الكريم ان قبل ثلاث ايام
اربع ايام دخل الجيش الاسرائيلي بنفس
الصوره وبنفس الوجه ودخلوا الى بيت احد
المواطنين وا وابلغوا ان هذا البيت سيهدم
او او هدم البيت المهم يعني يوميا
اقتحامات انت تتخيل وضع ان المخيمات
الفلسطينيه تكون في حاله اما ان تقتحمها
القوات الاسرائيليه وتعتقل من تعتقل وتهدم
بيت من تهدم بيته او تقتحمها القوات
الفلسطينيه تحت اي عنوان كان هذا مشهد هذا
مشهد غريب غير مقبول هذا اولا ثانيا يا
عزيزي هناك خلط مقصود و وهو ذكي بالمناسبه
ولكن لا ينطلي على ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
الخلط بينما هو جنائي يعني بمعنى اعتقال
مطلوب جنائيا ارتكب جنايه معينه واعتقد ان
لا احد في الشعب الفلسطيني لا احد من
كوادر فتح لا احد من قياده فتح ممكن ان
يشكل له غطاء وبين ان تعتقل كادر فلسطيني
كادر فتحاوي قيادي فتحاوي تعتقله لانه
يطالب بوحده حركه فتح او تحاول ان تمنع
بالقوه وتريد ان تقتحم المخيم كما حدث في
الامعري لان مجموعه من كادر فتح تداعت
لتقول اننا مع وحده فتح اننا مع الحفاظ
على المشروع الوطني الفلسطيني اننا ندعم
اي جهد عربي لتوحيد وحده فتح انت انت انت
انت هنا سيد ابوزيده انت هنا يعني
نقلتنا بشكل سلس للمحور الثاني لاننا نريد
ان نعرف بعد الفاصل ما هي التداعيات
المحتمله سواء على المشهد الفلسطيني سياسي
او على المشهد الامني وهذا مرتبط ببعضه
طبعا لنا عوده بعد الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي تناول فيها اسباب التوتر الذي
شهده مخيم بلاطه في مدينه نابلس بالضفه
الغربيه وتداعيات ذلك على المشهد السياسي
والامني في الضفه الغربيه سيد احمد غنيم
في في رام الله قبل قليل لم لم تشاء ان ان
ان تخوض في الجانب الامني لما جرى وربما
معك حق ولكن الان سنخوض في الجانب السياسي
فبالتالي لا مفر من من
مناقشته كثيرون يعتقدون بان جوهر الموضوع
الان هو الازمه العميقه داخل حركه فتح
هناك البعض من الموالين للرئيس وزعيم
الحركه الرئيس ابو مازن البعض ممن يسمون
بالمتجمد دحلان البعض من الغاضبين وليسوا
بالضروره من مؤيدي دحلان هذا يجعل من
الحركه تتمزق وهنا التعبير ل مركز كارنجي
للشرق الاوسط حركه تتمزق هل نحن فعلا امام
احد تجليات هذا ال
التوصيف لا انا بعتقد انه الازمه اعمق من
هيك واكثر عمق ولا يجوز حصرها بهذه
الجزئيه الازمه في حركه فتح ازمه كبيره
وعميقه و وهي ليست بمعزل عن ازمه الاقليم
باكمله الاقليم باكمله دول الاقليم عدد
كبير من دول الاقليم يكاد ينهار امام سؤال
التغيير اي والتغيير الديمقراطي نحن في ب
نعتقد انا من ال الجزء الذي يعتقد بداخل
حركه فتح باننا يجب ان نمتلك يعني رؤيه
ودرجه عاليه من الحكمه وان ناخذ الامور
الى طريقه تؤدي الى التغيير الامن
وباعتقادي ان الاخ ابو مازن الاخ الرئيس
ابو مازن يعني مسؤول ان ياخذ حركه فتح
الان ان يقود بنفسه عمليه التغيير الامن
في داخل حركه فتح وفي داخل السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه وفي منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
نحن لا نكود نار لا نريد ان ندخل الى الى
الى تغيير يؤدي بنا الى فوضى كالتي تحدث
في الاقليم او في دول الاقليم هناك عناصر
قوه كبيره في داخل المجتمع الفلسطيني
تستطيع ان تؤازر عمليه
التغيير الامن وهذه محكومه بالنظام و
بوثيقه الاستقلال وب انظمه حركه فتح
وبالقانون الفلسطيني وهذا وهذا التغيير
الامن سي هذا
التير التغيير الامن انا اخذ عبارتك
تحديدا هذا التغيير الامن هي التي تقول ما
يسمى بالرباعيه العربيه مصر السعوديه
الامارات وا الاردن تحاول الدفع باتجاه ان
يسعى الرئيس محمود عباس
الى توحيد الحركه لملمت جراحها و اعطاه
فرصه لمحمد دحلان هل تعتقد بان هذا
التغيير الامن التي تدفع باتجاه ما يسمى
بالرباعيه العربيه يمكن ان يلقى فرصته في
الضفه الغربيه
الان انا اتحدث عن التغيير الامن برؤيتي
اما الرؤيه التي انت طرحتها يعني ربما انت
مسؤول عن طرح هذه الرؤيه المتعلقه
برؤيه الرباعيه العربيه انا
شايفيه المسؤول عن نقله المسؤول عن نقه
المراقبين الذين يكتبون ذلك لست انا
المسؤول عنها
تفضل اخي اخي اخي محمد الرباعيه العربيه
او ما يسمى بالرباعيه العربيه مشغول الان
في سؤال يتعلق ب بحركه فتح والاقصى يقتحم
من قبل المستوطنين يوميا مش مشغوله لا
بموضوع الاحتلال ولا بموضوع الاساسي وهو
مواجهه ايه الاحتلال نحن يجب ان نصيغ
علاقه ضمن المنظومه العربيه صحيحه لسنا في
صدد احداث مواجهه مع ال المنظومه العربيه
المحيطه نحتاج الى مؤازره ومسانده الكل
العربي على قاعده اساسيه اننا لا نتدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه للدول العربيه وانه اعتقد
ان ليس هذا كان شعار يعني يؤمن به كل
ابناء اي حركه فتح احنا امامنا مؤتمر هذا
المؤتمر لكل عضو في حركه فتح الحق ان ياتي
الى هذا المؤتمر وان يقول ما لديه ويعرض
ما لديه عندما نتحدث عن عن عن التغيير
الامن انا اتطلع ان يكون هذا التغيير
الامن بضمانه القانون الفلسطيني وايضا
ضمانه النظام الداخلي لحركه فتح وان يقود
الرئيس ابو مازن بنفسه عمليه التغيير
الامن نحن في وضع صعب نحتاج الى استعاده
وحده النظام السياسي الفلسطيني واستعاده
وحده الوطن الفلسطيني وهذا لا يتم بصب
الزيت على النار وانما هذا يتم بالجلوس
الى طاوه حوار فلسطينيه
داخليه ال تؤ اليه تغير حقيقه وصحيح اسف
هذا الجلوس حول طاوله واحده كيف يمكن ان
نؤمنه سيد سفيان ابو زايده بطريقه
فلسطينيه بحته لان لا احد ينكر بان محمد
دحلان مدعوم باطراف عربيه يضخ اموال لديه
لوبيات امنيه وسياسيه داخل الضفه الغربيه
وغزه هذا ما يقوله خصومه على الاقل كيف
يمكن ترتيب الوضع الداخلي لفتح بعيدا عن
هذا الاستقطاب الذي يجعل دول عربيه تتدخل
ويجعل الساحه الفلسطينيه عرضه لتجاذب ليست
من صميم حركيه المجتمع
الفلسطيني يعني انا سمعت كلمات جميله من
الاخ احمد غنيم حول النظام حول حول النظام
وحول القانون وحول احترام احتو الاخ ابو
مازن وضروره ان يحتوي الجميع يا عزيز هذه
هي المشكله المشكله الاساسيه انه لا يوجد
احترام للنظام انا اتحدث عن نظام حركه فتح
ولا يوجد احترام للقانون الفلسطيني ولا
يتصرف الرئيس عباس على انه رئيس لكل
الفلسطينيين ورئيس لكل الفتحاويين هذه هي
جوهر المشكله لو ان الرئيس عباس يتصرف كما
تصرف الرئيس ياسر عرفات على مدار عشرات
السنوات التي قاد فيها حركه فتح والسلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومنظمه تحرير حيث كان
فارد كوفيته على كل الفلسطينيين الفتحاوي
وغير الفتحاوي والحم سوي والجبهات قبل
الفتحاوي لو ان الرئيس عباس مالهش كوفيه ل
يفرد عبايته على كل الفلسطينيين وعلى كل
الفتحاويين صدقني لن نكون بحاجه لا رباعيه
ولا ل خماسيه ولا لاي تدخل هذا اولا ثانيا
يا
عزيزي المؤتمر الذي يتحدث عنه الرئيس عباس
هل
الاخ المنتخب في العض المجلس التشريعي
والقيادي المعروف جهاد طمليه الذي اتخذ
الرئيس عباس قرارا بطرده حط شحطه تحت طرده
من حركه فته هل هذا سيشارك في المؤتمر
السابع ام انه لن يسمح له بالمشاركه هل
القوادر الذي يتم اعتقالهم هؤلاء سيشارك
في المؤتمر السابع ام هؤلاء لن يشاركوا في
المؤتمر السابع اذا كيف ستكون مخرجات هذا
المؤتمر هل هذا مؤتمر سيوحد حركه فتح
ثالثا يا عزيزي
دحلان وانا وكل القيادات التي ممكن ان
تصنفها انها قريبه من دحلان يقول اننا نمد
ايدينا وستبقى ايدينا معلقه في الهواء ان
لم يستقبلها احد ونحن ندعو ونطالب لوحده
حركه فته ونحن متنازلين عن كل الاجراءات
التعسفيه التي اتخذت بحقنا كرمال عيون فتح
وكرمال عيون القضيه الفلسطينيه
تداعى تداعى المئات من كوادر حركه فتح
بالمناسبه اليوم كان في الخليل وقب وامس
كان في في في في الامعري وغدا سيكون في
لبنان ماذا يقولون نحن نريد حركه فتح ماذا
كان الرد عليهم في في الامعري في الامعري
كل قوه الامن استنفرت كل الاجهزه الامنيه
استنفرت لمنع اجتماع وفقا للقانون انا
اريد ان اذكر اخي وعزيز وعزيزي احمد غنيم
وفقا للقانون الفلسطيني وهو كان عضو مجلس
تشريعي وفقا للقانون الفلسطيني لا ي لا
يجوز للسلطه التنفيذيه ان تمنع اجتماعا
مغلقا في قاعه مغلقه لا يحتاج الى اذن ولا
يحتاج الى اشعار كل الاجهزه الامنيه
اجتمعت لكي تمنع كوادر من حركه فتح لعقد
اجتماع يدعو الى وحده هذه الحركه يعني
طالما الامور يعني اسمح لي اسمح لي طالما
الامور بعد اذنك طالما وصلت الامور في
داخل حركه فتح الى الى هذا الحد وربما
تحسم في المؤتمر وقد لا تحسم وقد يؤجل
المؤتمر بغض النظر هناك مساله مهمه وسيد
خليل عساف هو منسق لجنه الحريات العامه
وعضو قياده تجمع الشخصيات المستقله في
الدفه الغربيه هذه الشخصيات المستقله في
الضفه الغربيه كيف يمكن لها ان تلعب دورا
في تهدئه الامور من الناحيه الامنيه في
الضفه الغربيه وفي
محاوله تقريب وجهات النظر ان كان لها هذه
الامكانيه
في موضوع الفتحاوي الذي
تابعناه يعني انا حضرت قاطعتني عند اخر
جمله وكنت يعني حاب اني اكملها انا اقوله
فتح العمود الفقري للثوره الفلسطينيه وهذه
حقيقه من من لا من لا يؤمن بها فانه لا
يؤمن بان هناك ثوره فلسطينيه ولا يحترم
دماء الشهداء وبالتالي هذه حركه العظيمه
يجب ان تتوحد هذه الحركه العظيمه يجب ان
ترفع عنها الضغوط لقتلها واغتياله انا
اقول بان هذه الحركه يتم هجوم عليها هجوم
منسق وكانه لا يوجد عندنا احتلال الاحتلال
لا يريد لهذه الحركه ان تكون ولا لغيرها
لان الاحتلال له برامجه وينفذ برامجه وانا
اقول يعني اخاف ما يعني ان اقول جمله يعني
قد يعني تزعل البعض او قد يعني يحرج البعض
منها ما فائده حركه فتح وما فائده كل
الحركات الفلسطينيه اذا اصبحنا خارج الوطن
هل وجدت هذه الحركات لكي تتقاتل هل وجدت
هذه الحركات لكي تبقي الانقسام كما هو هل
وجدت هذه الحركات والفصائل لكي نقتل بعضنا
البعض هل ننقل العدوى والسم والاجرام الذي
حصل ما بين الاخوه في سوريا وفي ليبيا الى
هذا الوطن الذي يطردنا منه الاحتلال انا
امام قادات وهامات وطنيه اعتز بانني اكون
معها وانا اشاركها في هذا اللقاء واكون
معها في اماكن اخرى اقول لكم جميعا اتقوا
الله الشعب الفلسطيني يذبح نحن نهان
بناتنا تذبح على المخاصم انا لا اتكلم ان
شاء انا جئت هنا الى لكي انقل الصوت الى
الاخ الرئيس ابو مازن وال الاخ محمد دحلان
والى كل قيادي فلسطيني سواء كان محسوب على
الرئيس ابو مازن او على دحلان فلسطين اكبر
منكم جميعا فتح وحماس وغيرها ليست موجوده
قبل ان تكون فلسطين هناك الكثير من
الفصائل والقوى التي كانت وذهبت واقول لكم
ان الله لا ي لا يصلح من المفسدين ما يحدث
فساد ما يحدث افساد ما يحدث قتل لكل روح
وطنيه حقيقيه ثوروا انتم الذين يجب ان
تثوروا على قياده دكم على الرئيس ابو مازن
وعلى دحلان وعلى كل شخص لكي تقولوا كفانا
نحن نريد ان نعيش في هذا البلد فليات
الجيش الاسرائيلي
وليقترفوا
طن فلسطيني امام بيتي وحول بيتي ويسمعوا
اولادي نحن نعيش تحت احتلال نسيتم اننا
نعيش تحت احتلال لا انظر على احد ولكن هذه
صرخه اتمنى ان تصل الى الكل الفلسطيني لان
وجودنا وتمنى نتمنى ايضا نتمنى ايضا نحن
ان ان تصل شكرا لك سيد خليل عساف كنت معنا
من نابلس شكرا لضيفنا ايضا من رام الله
احمد غنيم وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من غزه سفيان
ابو زايده بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ه